goodnight take the candles my eyes are
too weary to read I could read you my
lady
a girl who knows how to read my brother
teaches me good night my green whelming
shut the door behind you
have you seen how the hens in the yard
packet each other each choosing the one
just week why didn't they it is Pekka
can you I'm not Noble
did you know I was not raised at court
my sister and I was sent as girls to a
convent in France even there there were
hands and they begged even the nuns but
I had my sister to defend me read to me
then you really
[Music]
tell me what is inside Bertha
good morning my lady where does love
reside
[Applause]
purfles madness
and remember it
[Music]
I hope your number
the king he's dead he has stolen my
crown from me you forget how to greet a
king vengeance is mine
Vidia
these are strange times in this castle
be afraid you will only be safe if you
are afraid we can escape come you my son
against me I think you feel as dangerous
they want me to marry another
it starts now
take up
vengeance madness a kingdom lost nothing
is it seats
you